Hey guys, what's up?
So, I'm so excited because they have
demos of Super Mario Run at the Apple Store
so i'm going to go in here
and i'm gonna give it a try
the game doesn't come out until
december 15
so really, the only way to play it
is to go play at the Apple Store!
so, let's go!
here it is
Super Mario Run!
Oh buddy! Tap to begin, alright.
-[Jenna] Are you excited?
Oh, i'm so excited
*mario sounds*
OK, it's easier with your finger
I feel like that takes away from the experience
Yeah it does
Ok, let's restart that
Shoot!
-[Jenna] *laughing*
-[iJ] I wasn’t ready
-[Jenna] It was a good idea in theory
-[Jenna] What are your initial thoughts?
So I think it's pretty cool
I know this is one of those games your probably just gonna keep playing
over and over and over and over and over again
Alright, I'm gonna go back to this beginning one
since the trial doesn't really let you do much
but I'm gonna try to get all the pink stars
Coins, pink coins
Starting pretty good
Oh no!
We got three pink coins
No, I missed-
Ok guys who did it. We got all the pink coins.
I'm feeling quite, quite completed
Oh no!
Now it turns to purple ones? Oh God!
So now I gotta find all of the purple coins
I've been looking but, it gets so much more difficult as you progress
So, as you see, the level has now changed and
the purple coin is-   Oh shoot! See I miss it already
Retry
Yes, purple coin
Like, look how hard this one is
No no no no no
I only need one more
No! Where did it, oh my God, and I just died!
Well, where the heck could that purple one be?
It's taking me back as far as I want
I don't even know where it's at
Well you guys get the point
That was Super Mario Run
They have it here as a demo at the Apple Store and it's actually really fun
I thought it was gonna be kinda basic
which, yes, it is basic but it was getting super addicting
because every time you collect all of the same color coins
You then carry on and it brings you to another level
where it gets more difficult to collect the next color
I'm not really sure how many of those there are but, man
(Rudolph the red nose Reindeer plays in background)
Won't you guide my sleigh tonight
Let me know what you guys think of the game and I will see you in my next video
So sorry I haven't been posting much
I have been so sick the past couple of days
that basically I've only been playing mobile games
So if you guys have any suggestions for games I could play
leave me some down in the comments below
they can also be android games because
now I've got a Pixel phone so, I'll see you  guys later
mistakes were made...
I screwed up
What'd you get under the tree? Nothing!
box of coal
Gosh I love holidays
Do you like Rosalina? Do you want her to be your mom?
Does she look like your mom?